there's been a drought declaration in
parts of england
in the last few minutes live to our
political correspondent joe pike joe
tell us more about what the environment
agency is saying
well simon the national drought group
met this morning this is chaired by the
environment agency but includes
government ministers water companies
other bodies like the met office they
have now announced that a
drought is declared in parts of the
southwest the southern
central england area and east of england
regions parts of those four regions
they're encouraging people to use
water wisely but say that the water
supplies will remain
resilient some argue the declaration of
a drought is largely a symbolic move
because it doesn't suddenly trigger uh
some
points of action doesn't uh trigger
changes but what stark symbolism this is
as you can see from the pictures from
the sky copter
today simon matching this announcement
making it clear that so much of this
supposedly a green and pleasant land is
currently dry and arid ultimately water
companies already have pre-agreed
drought plans they have hose pipe
bands already in place yorkshire waters
today of course adding to other
companies who've already made
announcements but the hope of water
companies and of the environment agency
is that this declaration in these four
areas
encourages people to change their
behavior and reduce their water
consumption as i say parts of the
southwest southern and central england
and east of england areas have moved
into drought status reducing water
consumption is a real challenge and last
year in every single
area of england water companies have
failed to meet their uh targets that is
something that they're hoping will
change with this uh big announcement but
it's not just a consumers who are a
challenge it's also farmers too who have
seen their crops are damaged grass not
growing to feed cattle we're certainly
likely to see a potato costs rise
because farmers will get a smaller crop
the message now from government is use
water wisely but water supply supplies
will remain resilient it's possible the
environment agency will separately apply
for drought orders but ultimately it's
up to water companies to put in place
their agreed uh drought plans they are
in charge of hosepipe bans and just to
recap parts of the southwest the
southern central england and east of
england have moved cymer into drought
status the public being told to use
their water wisely but water supplies
for now remain resilient